once you find your style as a motion
designer you'll also find yourself using
certain elements over and over again
these elements could be fonts textures
transitions or any other kind of visual
asset and creating a library of these
assets can save you a lot of time in the
long run here are some tips on building
your own asset Library identify the
assets you use most frequently take a
look at your past projects and make note
of the elements you find yourself using
over and over again once you've
identified your frequently used assets
organize them into categories and save
your assets in a centralized location
use a cloud-based service like Dropbox
so that you can easily access them from
any computer by building your own
library of assets you'll be able to save
a significant amount of time and
increase your overall efficiency as a
motion designer